hi Samuel leaves here and if you are
saving up or about to buy your first
home to live in then stop right now and
watch this video I want to talk to you
about the pros and cons of buying versus
renting so a lot of people that I speak
to are literally saving up to buy a
house to live in and it's they think
renting is dead money so they shouldn't
rent however I completely disagree
renting is not dead money the thing that
is really dead money is interest
payments on the house that you live in
let me explain what I mean if you rent a
house that you live in and then use the
deposit that you were gonna use to buy
the house to invest in properties the
money that you make from the property
investments you can then use to rent and
have way more leftover if you just buy a
house to live in and then you use your
whole deposit money or savings on buying
a house to live in but it's not an asset
because the definition of an asset is
something that puts money into your
pocket every single month and the house
that you live in if you own it just not
I hope I'm making sense right here let's
say you have 50,000 pounds if you use
that to buy a house just one house to
live in yourself even if the house
rockets in value over time then you're
no better off than everybody else
because everybody's house has gone up
but if you use it to buy to cheaper
houses that you rent out then you're in
a much stronger position and I am NOT a
hypocrite saying this because I am a
renter the house that I live in I rent I
rent more than one house sometimes I
love it I love the freedom of it you
know when I moved into my big beautiful
barn conversion just over a year ago
thank God that I rented that barn
conversion and did not buy it for many
reasons reason number one is because
after living it for a year I've realized
I don't like it I don't like living in a
barn conversion so that's one reason
when you rent you can figure out what
you like a little bit more if you want
to buy and you've got lots of property
investments and you're financially
independent and you want to buy then
fine but I'm not gonna buy until I've
finished having all the children I want
to have and until I know where I want to
live forever that's that's when I'll buy
and it could be a few years away rent
where you live and then invest in
property elsewhere so that is my little
tip for today I've just been speaking to
a lady one of my mentees this afternoon
and she's got money in the bank quite a
large sum of money and she was about to
invest it into a house to live in which
was actually in London it would like
wiped out all her savings and I've just
shown her how she can use that money to
invest it in properties and with the
income she can rent the same house that
she wanted to in London and have way
more left over and then done with in
fact she can also with the amount of
money that she's got left over she can
save that up and then in a couple of
years time she can still buy the London
house anyway
so you know just when you're buying
properties just use your head use your
formulas not your feelings some people
are just so get wrapped up with their
feelings they just want to own the house
that they live in
why what you want I don't know how she
living so much I mean the only advantage
it has may be when you own the house you
live in is that you don't have a
landlord to ever have to answer to but
then there's so many cons there's so
many comes like you're not free you're
not free to just travel you're tied down
to a house you're tied down to an area
yeah just rent where you live guys I am
a proud renter so I hope you are too let
me know what you think below in the
comments if you think this video is
useful if you think people need to see
this and hear this then please do share
I'd love to see your comments and
thoughts below too
[Music]